et la première chose c'est le haut
niveau du vigan si c'est pas si ce n'est
pas joli ça va pas attirer le client
nous sommes ici au marin dans une
boulangerie tout près de la marina
albert 46 ans dont des javelles métier
début de sa journée il vient de suivre
une formation de pâtisseries fines au
centre de formation pour adultes de
chartres pari gagnant il a été recruté
faire plaisir aux clients
en fait moi lorsque je travaillais je
pense aux clients d'abb ont fait le
clown aime pas on va pas vendre ce qui
était prévu ce qui est normalement
suite à la formation par antoine travail
à nos compétences que qu'ils allaient
embauché certaines personnes quoi ils
sont dix martiniquais de 25 à 53 cents à
s'être rendu en eure et loir pour cette
formation de haut niveau dans un secteur
manifestement en grande demande
ah oui aujourd'hui on à l'embauché en
show constants permanents vraiment de
salariés qualifiés dans le domaine de la
boulangerie et de la pâtisserie et il
est très difficile de recruter en local
et des collaborateurs
la formation s'est déroulée sur deux
sites à chartres est également au cfa de
rivière-salée la vraie valeur provient
de chartres on a aussi bien du coup
l'affluence de la métropole où les
produire les clients recherchent des
produits de la pâtisserie fine et le cfa
mais tout le monde sait manque de moyens
pour justement apporter une formation
vraiment complète aux étudiants nous
avons des compétences locales qu'est ce
qu'il est important de garder d'
exploiter notamment sur le travail des
produits locaux comme nos fruits etc
mais c'est vrai que on voulait aussi
qu'il y ait une expertise qui soit mais
différente qu'ils soient amenés charte
et riant et en cfa avec une très très
bonne réputation notamment
au plan national donc nous avons combiné
les deux organismes de formation pour
offrir une formation complète à nos
stagiaires loeb coentreprise de
proximité est l'organisme qui finance la
formation
son coup de maître a été d'être à
l'écouté de la profession en injectant
près de 200000 euros pour cette
opération
nous avons fait une campagne de
recensement sur les boulangeries
pâtisseries de martinique
nous avons identifié donc ce besoin en
recrutement sur des pâtissiers avec des
compétences en pâtisserie haut de gamme
et donc du coup c'est naturel avec le
pôle emploi de travailler conjointement
pour répondre à ce besoin par le biais
d'une formation une formation l'occasion
d'apprendre de se remettre en question
de confirmer une vocation
et pour cette session c'est sûr la
passion était au rendez vous tous les
échanges que j'ai pu avoir avec le
groupe où les apprenants
individuellement mon pm découvrions que
j'avais à faire en fait à des passionnés
à des personnes vraiment passionnés par
leur métier et qui ont choisi louis qui
ont choisi en fait cette voie par
passion
j'ai eu cet appel à la pâtisserie
tardivement après après mettant mes 30
ans et c'est tombé à point nommé
vraiment g
a pris d'autres techniques de nouvelles
techniques de nouvelles manières de
faire et
qui sait un petit peu plus pointu c'est
une suite poumon cap2 préparer la
mention complémentaire pour avoir plus
de professionnalisme
et puis moi personnellement
dans le bitume continuité pour une
création d'entreprise
trois stagiaires ont déjà signé un
contrat pour les autres cela devrait
arriver très vite
la martinique compte environ 230
boulangerie pâtisserie
selon le syndicat de la profession